hey guys this is Pete peppers from candy
crush soda saga tips com and this is a
candy crush soda level 462 walkthrough
with some tips in the commentary we had
a couple people asking about this one
and it can be a little bit tricky so I'm
going to go through as I play and
explain what I'm trying to do the middle
column is really the first thing that
you want to set your sights on and we
also want to take those shots like that
where we get straight up and down
striped candies that will shoot the the
floating pieces the you won't be able to
finish it just with the stripes but if
you're setting things up like here we're
going to try to drop another even though
we already have a colored bomb we're
going to try to drop another one if we
can I'm going to make this because we're
going to need big combos in order to in
order to be able to clear mall so i'm
going to i'm looking for strict like I'm
looking for stripes vertical stripes so
I'm also looking to make another color
bomb if I can hear you know I'll take
that anyways wrapped candies will be
good a rap candy what they wear the
color bomb will be good if you have that
color on the bottom like we do now but
I'm just taking some extra time to fire
off what i have and i got lucky enough
to get another color bomb here so
obviously we're going to match these
together so in general we want to clear
out the top so that our fish will be
more effective which that does for us
obviously you're not going to get one
every single time but you're going to
want to do that and here you know it's
pretty obvious choice to use the pretty
obvious choice to use the sprinkle shell
on
blue it depends a lot of times I'll pick
whichever sometimes you won't have very
many of a color on a board so a lot of
times I'll pick whatever is at the
bottom like if it was how it is right
now I would pick the red rather than the
blue the blue is nice because it
recharges it you can see we're up to
like two-thirds full right there but you
want to take whichever one is going to
be the most effective at the time and
like I was saying you know fish are
pretty useless when they're still
frosting at the top of the board so you
know you want to clear that out with
combos while you're making stripes and
wrap lunch stripes because those will
take out two rows of you sometimes and
that way when we get down to the end
like we are now we don't have to worry
about the fish everything that we use a
fish for now we'll hit one of these
important pieces of frosting so you know
that's one thing to keep in mind so now
you know we get this nice little strike
in the middle that that's always there
that will show up eventually though it
gets things going at the bottom for you
I want to set up another color bomb here
so I can drop this this this one down
and that was actually really fortunate
so now we got fish on top and I wanna
I'm going to go ahead and use these red
fish first because it shouldn't hurt
anything and even though I dropped it
down there it doesn't hurt anything and
now we'll use this because there weren't
that many yellow on the board so I just
wanted to go ahead and knock out a
couple pieces of frosting and try to get
a couple more yellow pieces on the board
when you get down to this part the
sprinkles all here we'll use for orange
because there's one double frosting
underneath orange usually you won't have
as many moves as I have right now i
played this a few times already and I
didn't I ran out of moves before I
finish so you just want to plan things
out like here I'm match the green so I
can get that red to drop and it's the
same concept because you know we'll
probably make some fish here so
we're going to want them to to get the
really hard pieces of frosting all right
so we coming into the color bomb there
that just will fall in place and that
will happen quite a bit actually once
you start working towards the bottom
make a fish I'm trying to combo this
color bottom of something and I'm gonna
make one more fish just so I know finish
and then here like we could make the
match with this with the striped let me
pause this for saying we could make the
match with the striped we have one we
don't really have any that are hitting
there you know if they're not really
facing the place where we need to go so
our best hope with doing that would be
to set off the fish and we can actually
just go ahead and use our sprinkle shell
to hit read it will hopefully take the
one off on the right and then the red
fish will go and finish off the last one
so if you're really low on moves you
know those were the kinds of decisions
where you have to like stop and think
you know like what's the best thing to
do obviously the coolest thing to do is
to match the stripe with the color bomb
but it doesn't necessarily it doesn't
guarantee that we'll finish the red
doesn't guarantee that we'll finish
either it gives us a good chance and
then we still have the color gone left
if we need it so I opted for the red red
sprinkle shell on the red instead and
we'll see if that works and it did so
just in general you know you the first
thing you want to do is get rid of that
square in the middle at the top the
square of ice that's above the above the
taught in the middle column you want to
get that out of the way if you can you
know try to make a maybe a wrap plus a
stripe combo because there is a striped
underneath it but get that other way so
you have something to make make your
specials the bottom you can't really
make matches down there in the beginning
so you're just going to kind of watch
and use your sprinkle shell to make some
damage down there if you can otherwise
set up your stripes to hit those
floating squares in the middle and then
just take your time and look for bigger
combos to clear the whole board and you
should get through before too long so i
hope this helped please like the video
and subscribe to our channel so that you
can get all the latest tips videos that
we make and we'll see you real soon
thanks